Happening Now full-scale Talent Heather
Mills on very small detail that's right
proof bigger isn't always better Lauren
negretti joining us live from Gold Coast
with more on the tiny intricacies of the
mini show hi Lauren
hey good morning that's right yes lots
of details small scale it's actually a
memory foam check that out memory foam
chair you see that bounce back now if it
looks lifelike that's because you know
this actually inspired by real life
scale things here I've got Paris Renfro
talk more about it tell me about how you
got started with your PRD Miniatures so
I used to be a full-size designer and so
I did a lot of coffee tables case goods
things like that and rather than do a
lot of drawings I actually made models
for for my clients for the proposals and
they kind of took off like a lot of
people were like wow these are really
cool can we keep these and so I started
doing more and more of them and then in
2008 when the economy crashed I really
was kind of I similar to covid forced to
recreate myself and so I started making
my designs but just in miniature and
I've been doing that ever since yeah
like you said that really blew up and
you had an interesting point too you
know the pandemic's all big shift in in
getting all this out here the pandemic
saw big shift and getting this out here
too yes definitely we've I a lot of our
show here we have a lot of different art
citizens that are coming in some of them
actually lost their jobs with covid and
so they started doing just trying to do
different arts and things that they
could do because everybody was
quarantined at home and it's really been
exploding and there's a lot of
inspiration out there and that's what
this show is about too is kind of
bringing people together so that they
can all you know share their different
arts and and get to meet them because
everybody's been used to kind of seeing
each other on Instagram or all these
different you know social media but it's
not the same right no and we'll geek out
over this and this will be for sale come
Saturday Sunday as well yes definitely
perfect well we're going to have just a
bunch more artists here to talk about
you guys if you're if you're hungry I
got some Ramen there for you too we're
going to talk more with this artist here
Pat coming up next in the next half hour
for now live in Las Vegas Lorna Grady 8
news now it's a diet style Ramen a mini
it's miniature raw meat like it's like
it's a Ramen shot
I love that that is that is
a little bit thank you Lord thank you
Lauren